[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you shoot big loads
what bro do you shoot ropes like what do
you got what
is your small quantity you're not like a
dribbler are you i mean dude i ain't no
[ __ ]
pete maravish you know what i'm saying i
shoot [ __ ] loads whoa really i'll
show you i'll show you
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's line up
if we stood at the [ __ ] end of this
table
uh-huh and i'm backed up even a couple
days
i'm i mean i'm getting distance on this
team no you're not yes i am
yes i am wow that's incredible yeah i
mean and also like you know how you have
like pumps right like an orgasm is like
it's like your your dick goes like yeah
right how many do you go through you
think
like count them out in your head
six seven eight maybe yeah the last two
are week week week though you got to be
in my body to feel them yeah exactly
yeah i'm like on a bad day 12
13.
on a on a really strong day i'm up to
like 16.
yeah oh my god man i went to a doctor
about it
that's crazy you know what he told me
why you're lucky
yeah
you're like a guy shut up yeah i don't
tell anybody
yeah damn bro bust nuts dog
that's crazy i mean i bust them too i
bust probably
you know good pretty good nuts but i
don't do
i don't think i'm
you know i'm gonna win anything now okay
here's what i'm here here's what i'm
struggling with so i've been sushi
shamed we both have
many times so many times by both chefs
and servers well they're like that's too
much food and i'm being polite by not
doing their accent so they'll say like
that's enough just do the accent
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it just feels more organic yeah so it's
too much food
so yeah
oh my god they've actually been like
don't order this amount and i'm like all
right
and then like
you know start like are you still hungry
yeah okay i'll play you i'll play you
play the guy okay because i don't know
what you're saying okay excuse me ching
chong um
hey hey
nobody
[Music]
number three the boat i mean the boat
with all the sushi on it how many
friends come with you
[Laughter]
what did you even say
he knows what i said
it was the most racist thing ever oh my
god
hi everyone just wanted to get on here
to tell you all that
i think i'm leaving tick tock
no
i've enjoyed all the friendships thanks
for turning the volume up
background some dramas going on
no
i didn't know you were allowed to be
honest if you were over 19.
like i had no idea that there were 60
year olds leaving tick tock oh there are
emotional making an announcement you're
like emotionally going i have made a lot
of friendships here it's like that's
illegal
it's against the law
what do you think you've made a lot of
prejudices here right what are you
talking about i mean we had been day
drinking in florida yeah my family
and we saw these little kids like fifth
graders yeah um
by the pool and this place and uh
we walked in on them and they were
choreographed we're like what are you
doing and we've been drinking right and
they're like oh and they're in their
school uniforms they're like we're
making a tick tock and we both were like
we're on tick tock and
and uh they were like oh okay these are
like 10 11 year olds they're gonna get
kidnapped and then they're like what's
your handle and i was like i've spelled
it out for them and then as we walked
out i realized that the last
one i had posted was me pulling my
nipples and going like
that
but i was like oh we gotta go we gotta
we gotta get out of here
you know he [ __ ] did a lot of creepy
things down there man uh
rest in peace you know he was good to me
ever
he did a lot of creepy things it wasn't
good
yeah he was a creepy [ __ ] living with
his brother
poor guy said that at the memorial
service i would die
give me things rest in peace he's a real
and the guys talking like they give a
memorial in the back you hear you're
like this is such a [ __ ] last time i
saw this guy was doing blow off the
strip his ankle
and this candy he's a loving father sure
yeah he should have seen him that night
how much he loved his skin when he had
his tongue up that [ __ ] yarm's
[ __ ] [ __ ] with coke island
[Music]
does ching chong really not mean
anything
i think
means um
um
hello maybe can we can we just address
something about it though
it's a fun thing to say yeah it's like
it's unfortunate that it has negative
you know racial connotation because it
really
it really feels slows off the tongue it
feels like tell me
tell me you guys have seen there is a
very offensive meme okay it's it's a
mentally handicapped asian guy and he's
a maestro of an orchestra i know exactly
what you're talking about and it says
and a one and a three and a chin chunk
potato yeah and it's
easily the funniest meme i've ever seen
in my entire yeah right is it offensive
yeah yeah it's just very funny very
funny but also like it also it would be
nice if it was acceptable to use for
like you know what i mean like let's say
you were like hey uh you know my my mom
made this dish and i was like what is it
and then you could be like it's just
some ching chong [ __ ] you know
you know
i got blind drunk with what's the the
old the guy that was running
houston improv
that that guy no not not a trey no the
creepy guy the creepy guy
yeah yeah yeah he's a creepy fellow the
creepy guy's dad the other guy no no no
he's a creepy [ __ ] they they sent them
to arlington he's the rapist he's the
truth i wasn't singing yeah yeah they
put him they put him in they put him in
arlington
you know dan murr was a [ __ ] dirty
coach
like a like a filthy coaching
he would get so coked up that you think
he had a stroke his lip would turn like
his lip would just go upwards
so one night at everybody for years one
night when i had the really bad sleep
apnea and i really wasn't sleeping i
didn't know what uh i didn't know what
god
did rest in peace i didn't know what the
sleep apnea what the effects were yet
i passed out one night really hard and
also i wake up to the door banging and
it's joe rogan pre-marijuana when he was
[ __ ] miserable
i always say he was an ape you ever see
the evolution of an animal that's when
he was an eight yeah if your parent
doesn't know that you're smoking meth
and you're out in the streets and you're
doing stuff that's on them man they
should have had an eye on you yeah it's
not your responsibility
like how do you feel oh my god you can't
let it go
first of all
i'm bobby off the hook with the dick
sucks
were you naturally good at it because i
feel like oh my god i feel like i feel
like yeah as a guy you're like i know
what i like so you have like certain
skills right well that's silly
i just want to say this to you and i'm
not going to go into detail about it
okay but
when you're young you don't know what
you like yeah so i think it was pretty
much amateur hour okay you know i mean i
would probably like i wouldn't go down
to the sack or the taint yeah right and
go you like that
right i think it was more like you know
licking the tip and going you know you
know does that suffice right
what
it's just funny
yeah
like if i was but look how happy this is
never this joyful yeah if i was never
a gay man yeah and i was and you were
gay
and you and i were having sexual
sexualities with each other
you and i would probably be like um we
probably know what we we liked you know
of course and we would do extra things
yeah you know yeah to please ourselves
sure i would like to please you thanks
yeah you're welcome i like that but yeah
he was a kid babe
kids don't know how to give blow jobs in
case you're wondering i mean exactly
were you blowing adults or no no no no
no oh my god you can't let it go again
it's just like you can't let it go kenya
and this is your fault sweetie do you
like that yeah yeah
it's your fa oh my goodness so check
this out this guy yeah smoked mess
with his brother
something cool happened
my brother didn't believe me
but when he smoked with me he pulled out
his dick i couldn't believe how big his
dick was he jacked off in four strokes
and shot the most [ __ ] he's ever shot
and he's fine he has no rock problems at
all
his dick is even harder and thicker and
even more kind he leaves me now
this is a pretty good ad for meth i
think right yeah yeah and i was like i
want to take a truck stop shower too you
know
i want to get it yeah but don't you run
the risk of getting stabbed
you get you also run by like drifters
and you also could like meet a cool guy
cool
yeah
well then the truck stop shower
conversation led to what else happens at
truck stops right good thing
i was like hey are there a really he's
like lot lizards
and i go
i like this i like the phrase a lot less
a lot lizards he's like oh yeah they're
there
i go what happens they knock on your
door they knock on your door they'll
just come up sneak through the
lizard and then you know
they they ask you if you want some and i
go are they everywhere he goes not
everywhere he's like california sure has
a few the nice weather yeah a lot of
lizards aren't afraid and sometimes it's
a different arrangement sometimes he
said like you'll know like the driver
will like obviously
re like knows someone in the area you'll
see like cars
pulling in
that there clearly it's been arranged
like maybe arranged beforehand yeah like
the guy knows that this girl works in
this area this lizard so the lizard will
show up
and then
have i was like oh what's that like
i don't know about that yeah sure
he doesn't know
i'm like you he's like deb i don't know
you know about these lot lizards i don't
know
i'm so innocent
i'm just a dummy yeah i wouldn't be in a
lot lizard but i would i would like i
mean i think a fun fantasy would be like
a stranded girl you know who's like
moving along i don't have any way to get
to
i already know where this is
dirty tom dallas i'm stuck here i'm like
oh i'm going to dallas you are
yeah come on over and then she gets on
the bus i'm like now you got to pay the
toll you know
and then like what you do is
he's really encouraging
right now yeah you you just wear her out
and you know and wear her out what do
you mean babe you know and the bang bus
yeah yeah yeah well you told me you guys
take your turns on the line that's what
i'm saying well i'm saying with this
stranded girl yeah as like she gets the
business from me
i give it to my stranded girl i give her
to the opening act he runs through her
and the driver takes it his turn
and then we drop her off nowhere close
to that
[Laughter]
wow that sounds like it's like where is
this i'm like montana good luck yeah
yeah you shouldn't hitchhike you stupid
[ __ ] there you go that wasn't gonna go
that far we waited three hours for you
to arrive
and and we would have waited forever
because i'm sorry i already apologized
i'm sorry you were the tomas sir thomas
sir thomas okay and we know um i'll tell
you this well this is a this is this is
actually just more wholesome than the
only other time that i completely forgot
i was scheduled to do a podcast yeah so
this is the second time yeah today i've
said a big tennis match you know i was
out in the sun i got home
shower and laying on the couch literally
andrew's like let me know when you get
there and i was like [ __ ]
right and i just panicked yeah got my
kid dressed and i was like yeah you guys
got to watch them and i just jumped in
the car and
the last time was in 20
god i want to say it says 2012. holy
[ __ ] but i remember it like it was
yesterday and i had agreed to do the
scar brothers podcast which is one of
the best
they're great they're great guys and
they're like hey will you uh you know
come on on friday and we'll see you at
at noon and i go yeah okay
i'm
jerking off
looking at my phone
watching porn like stroking my d and
it's just you know the the iphone thing
it's like randy sclar and i'm like and
as soon as i see his name i'm like [ __ ]
so he's like are you close and i was
like to coming yeah
uh do you have a guess okay okay now the
fact that she can speak clearly means
there's nothing in her mouth
so i'm gonna go with not dick sucks
originally i thought dick sucks obvi so
it's not a dick suck i'm thinking she
said there's a fist and a [ __ ]
yeah good good ear thank you
i'm gonna go with she's got a fist in
her b-hole
and a [ __ ] in her v-hole
wow uh nadav can you weigh in
yeah i'll say christina you're really
close uh there is a fist in the v-hole
and there's nothing in the beat
he sounds kind of bummed out about wow
why are you so [ __ ] what's the problem
well i got a text last night
at around nine i was getting ready for
bed
because you know we have early call
times on show days yeah and and tom just
sends me very vague links to
heavyard.com
that are just category links yeah and
he's like hey go into here
find stuff that sounds funny looks funny
and prep it for tomorrow and it's like
i'm supposed to be in the studio in 12
hours and tom just assigned me half a
day's work yeah did you stay up till two
in the morning no i told him hey can we
push this too maybe next week he's like
get at least a couple
ah you're so where did you find this
website well here's the thing that's a
really cool story go ahead i have
learned what the r stands for in heavy r
dot com you don't have to share it
our no no no because i ruled out a lot
of the clips that i thought would have
been fun but i just learned it after you
told me don't worry about it who was one
of the most unique people that ever came
out to see you perform
or somebody that shocked you that that
was like at the show or something yeah
hmm
i'm trying to think ben i'm trying to
think of a good one too i don't have an
answer really but
did tyson ever come to go on any shows
tyson came to my show in pittsburgh yeah
wow that was that was pretty wild i mean
tyson chandler yeah yeah yeah
no it's weird i mean to be like hanging
out with mike tyson and the girl mike
tyson oh yeah like to like and have him
just like
hang out smoke cigarettes in your green
like in a green room smaller than that
room and you're just like what's up and
like
how many white dudes would it take to
jump mike tyson now at his age right now
yeah
depending on the type of dude um
what about you and me oh no we were dead
we would be dead i wouldn't be dead i
wouldn't do it listen to me man you
think that like
being the way i look
i was killing it in the 90s
i wasn't
because
imagine this look at this body yeah you
didn't have this body right okay you
didn't have you know you're why you
gotta make it like that i don't do
anything i mean that's what i'm thinking
but don't
i don't but you don't have what you know
what i have i think that you're wrong
because i don't care what you you're not
gonna it's not what i know but you're
not going to believe this but i
sincerely from the get-go found you to
found you attractive all right i mean
yeah she's like in high school i would
have dated dude no you wouldn't have
dated [ __ ] you would have never even
seen it
ugly oh yeah i [ __ ] up a ton of ugly
guys because i wasn't that cute either
when i first came from the philippines i
had a [ __ ] i wanted you [ __ ] back
then you know what i mean
to gum ratio it was i was a mess who
else could i couldn't have heard of that
statement she's like of course i would
have dated you i dated other ugly guys
my older sister i have an older sister
and a younger my older sister your older
sister's 92 92 years old wild it's crazy
yeah we're born so far apart um
but she uh she has been the
per the person at fault
in
13 or 14 car accidents what yeah take
her license away i know that's it what
state is this in
a few but mostly in wisconsin and
florida she's a national problem on the
road she's it's
unbelievable time out let me ask them
not to cut you off yeah in wisconsin
there isn't a three-strike loss so maybe
that's why she because you know that's
where she started driving okay because
because i don't know if you know this
this is we used to joke about this in
chicago wisconsin has no law it's in dui
culture if you get three steve duis you
have a license uh your license is
expelled for the rest of your life right
yeah well three strike law states
california yeah yeah most places that
are like that yeah if you have three
three duis you're done for doc yeah
wisconsin does not have a three strike
law for duis there was a woman
sorry to interject but there was a woman
i remember reading stories she had 12
duis i've always heard those stories but
wisconsin because wisconsin cops are
like come on betty get home will ya and
she's like all right she get it at home
they're like
wow she's gotta take you in come on we
got will you follow us will you follow
us can you like wisconsin has that like
drinking
country lifestyle where they're like
she's starting
yeah
when he falls asleep
we gotta take her in you know what um
it's really funny we'll do the podcast
live your mom's house live yeah and
people will come up to us and i'll be
like how's it going thanks for coming
they're like yeah i really like that
it's deep bro more
i'll be like thanks a lot man
and then they'll be like we we came out
kind of hoping to see that i'm like we
didn't advertise that
like you tell me how disappointed you
are yeah you wanted to see a different
movie like it's so we told you were you
honest when was the last time you got 69
69 i'm gonna i'm gonna be honest i know
that it was we it's i'm gonna say
six years at least six years no it's
been it's not that long 69
yeah it's it's not that long no it's
been a while but not not that long the
sex position
yeah yeah why are you asking personal
[ __ ] was what
he's [ __ ] bird because we were
talking about 69 you're doing about 69
and earlier
but uh that was nice you but the part
you're gonna really love so the gopro
hero4 blacks guess what they're called
what that one's wesley snipes
[Music]
that one's kimbo slice
and that's james winston
he's so black
not skin tone just behaviorally jameis
winston i can't decide whether i really
[ __ ] love the guy like if he's a
forrest gump of football or if he is
he's not the force cup
[Music]
have you ever witnessed a surgery
um no no have you
many really yeah i had the wild idea
that i wanted to be a doctor a surgeon
you did well this is young though yeah
sure sure so i was like a freshman in
high school
and i tell i'm like i think i want to be
a doctor
i mean i'm a freshman aren't your
parents like come on yeah of course but
i think they're like well this is a good
sign it's a good sign but also like he's
[ __ ] dumb he's not gonna do it he
can't get but i was like yes i do i mean
i'm very convincing you know they're
like okay
so
i go i think i want to be like a surgeon
though you know so yeah
my dad
calls his brother who's like a
well-known doctor who sets me up is your
dad a doctor by the way no okay his
brother
and uh
sets me up to go to the mayo in
jacksonville
and witness
surgery
like for a day to just be a part of it
like i get there seven a.m
and i'm a freshman i remember that the
one of the doctors goes what school do
you go to i was a kind of a big kid you
know yeah
i mean for a freshman in high school i
was probably uh i don't know five nine
five ten and like 185 or something so
full size and he was like what school do
you go to and i i say my high school and
he's like
that's a university and i go i'm in high
school he was like you're in high school
so i think he thought he was also eating
the other high school boys well he's
like he goes like
why are you like he thought he was going
to take like a college kid right right
and he's like so you're here i was like
i want to do this
and he was like
okay all right so i witnessed
13
surgeries that day holy [ __ ] they start
me like
first day like i'm at the hospital
6 30 in the morning yeah and this guy
he's like all right and he takes me and
like the first surgery we witness
is to an 87 year old woman
who's having a cyst removed from her
vagina oh my god and
i go in there and he's like you're gonna
stand here he goes
like so i'm standing
at the foot of the bed and you're
standing in like this
there's staring straight up yeah yeah
i'm covered and everything and he goes
uh go come here come here and he pulls
me aside he goes just so you know she's
not under so if you say something she
can hear it and i go she's awake for the
surgery yeah she's just like
anesthetized ah right right from below
the waist
do they start and like so there's this
87 year old [ __ ] just like wide open in
front of me i'm like all right that's
how you knew you were gay i knew i knew
it
and then
he kind of he's like they go in there
and then he
he's like here's the cyst and then he's
like holy [ __ ] like this is enormous so
they start bringing in other people to
look at it
and then they go like edith and she's
like yes he goes we're gonna take some
pictures
and she's like
okay we just want to post this stuff on
myspace this is wild we've never seen
one this size
so this is going to be in a journal
but your face won't be in the photos or
anything like that okay she just gives
like a rock on above it yeah [ __ ] yeah
and so they start taking pictures and
i'm sitting there like oh my god and
then he pops it and
yeah it's just like oozing
oh my god you believe that and he was
like what not something and i go yeah
yeah i'm gonna get into stand-up comedy
yeah yeah
you farted this morning uh horrendously
this morning
no was it last night
yeah
you get excited about that tour you
changed
i was uh we made sweet marital relations
and then afterwards we were you know
whatever later on and he goes you know
you're lucky i go why
he goes well i held in a fart for you
that whole time yeah and i go wow what a
lucky gal i am i feel like i should get
credit for that i feel like right i feel
like some guys would have let that go
and i was like nope like don't do that
right now
yeah i had just settled in
you know and i was like nah don't let
this go right now that's beautiful yeah
see he can appreciate it it's amazing
would your i get excited yeah
talking about this with you guys
would now would your wife be uh would
she consider it nice too that you do you
hold them in or do you yeah i'm trying
to try my best yeah and if i do
accidentally let one go i'd let
everybody know get out of the way get
out of the way yeah everybody clear
yeah yeah can i tell you something this
sounds i don't know if this is racist or
not
i never assumed the girl was white you
the girl that accused him yeah i figured
she was black why i don't know i just
never thought he'd hook up with white
chicks
like i just assumed well his girlfriend
then and now is black he has a black
girlfriend i just saw him as a guy who
would not be attracted to white chicks
well i think they they just know that
those snow bunnies are easy to get it
into because you know that like among
black guys the whole thing is that white
girls are [ __ ] right like that's the
whole thing no yeah for sure
they're like white chicks or white
chicks will will suck it we'll put it in
their ass we'll do it like white girls
are [ __ ] so they all seriously they
all just stick their dicks in them
because they're like they'll just do it
yeah
i'm saying among college athletes for
sure
really a hundred percent well i guess
the ones that like you see the black
dudes at the mall with like those ones
that are like
fours
like then maybe sure but like like
leanne [ __ ] good luck bush
the white chicks i hang out with are
horses but if you go on a college campus
and like
any big d1 basketball or football
program you're a black dude wait where's
this research coming from dude put it
out there and and
and tell me that i'm wrong
tell me that i'm wrong
they're getting their dick sucked
by i want to [ __ ] i want to quite i
want to call
one of my black friends really find out
oh please do
okay it's not a comic is it no no no no
but he's got he's got a comic
sensibility okay
he's uh i don't want to say who he is in
case he says something horrific here we
go yeah
all right let's call him and find out oh
i'd love i want to hear this so badly
what's his name oh you can't say i can
say i guess it's omar omar dorsey he was
in uh he's in eastbound and down okay
he's in the
uh he's the guy who i
i had come over and read the n word in
my book oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
wait which word the it's the never mind
he said never mind no no he said it like
a white guy
where is he
i love that you can't believe that
someone's not answering where is he yeah
like it's
awesome it's me yeah
the only person that doesn't answer when
i call is you you have reached the
voicemail of eight okay
all right so uh yeah he'll call back
some well yeah we'll get some some
clarification on that oh i know another
black dude call the other black dude um
all right what's his name sterling
sterling is such a black name
you know sterling sharp
hold on hold on
sterling
[ __ ]
oh here's omar perfect timing oh great
omar
what's going on hey uh you're on the
podcast i need to ask you i need to ask
you your opinion
yeah okay uh i'm with my buddy tom and
he was saying that that commonly known
at like like say like florida state or
like a big uh division one school
yeah that
that
black guy's opinions of white girls is
that they're
they're [ __ ] and easier to [ __ ] than
black chicks is that true
okay would you rather
everywhere you go
you have to run to get there i'm out on
that i don't know i don't even care what
the next one is
my back can't take it it's literally
like you go to the next room in your
house to sit like a five minutes
exactly
always running never stretching just
always running you always have to you
have to run somebody if someone knocks
on your front door you have to run there
you have to run on stage
boom boom boom boom yeah i'm out yeah i
don't i don't care what this is
or join isis all right isis let's get
those [ __ ] infidels
or every time you speak
you're shouting so you're basically a
toddler that you're just your soul
volume shout out like right well it hurt
my voice to do worse yes a little bit
of course
neither of these are going to be fine
but you have to go like the phony hello
yeah like that you you always
you
say everything in that range yeah and
you're standing i found a loophole
i find a
loophole i would just ignore people
oh so then i wouldn't have to talk to
him and then when they i'd just wait
till they say my name ten times and i'd
be like what so it made sense
there's the loophole
because you need you you need your
health you need your health
my body would just hurt so much if i did
that your sweet wife who you love be
like bill you gotta go yeah and then
she's like do you think you can take
your daughter to the park you're like
yeah and then your sweet daughter but i
could explain to him i have an
affliction
[Laughter]
ignore the tone of my voice i love you
more than life itself
you're my best friend
so love to go to the movies but you're
gonna have to do the purchase
he can't whisper during the movie yeah
he can he can shout it
he's one of my favorite actors yeah
definitely he could do it
i think the wife did it
he gets him a pop card yeah but i
actually because that would be fun once
my wife was into it i would just be
totally quiet
and you're having sex you like that
you feel so good
how many friends come with you
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way
[Music]